when somebody goes ahead and makes
bitcoin legal tender or adopts it which
now we're seeing in many other countries
so we just saw lugano switzerland
malaysia today just described that they
want to make bitcoin cryptocurrencies
legal tender there's numerous states in
the united states that more marketing
but but want to do it as well
is it actually the technology itself and
and what economic impact it creates or
is it more so become a flag in the
ground hey we want to be innovative we
want entrepreneurs we want to be
business friendly we want to be at the
forefront of this and that leads to the
positive impact of tourism gdp growth et
cetera like how do you think about
that
almost balance between the technology
itself versus the impact well let me
give you a scenario where bitcoin or
things like it might have a role in the
future okay uh the whole globalization
thread that has driven everything since
1945 that's what's breaking down right
now
and in in my second book action
superpower i think one of the things i
said is it doesn't really matter where
the break happens it's going to cascade
so the russia ukraine war was one of the
specific examples like i had there was
one of the persian gulf there's one in
east asia
if you move away from the trade
environment that we have it's not that
the dollar standard goes away it
probably becomes more important because
the united states will be even more
emotionally disconnected from other
sections of the world and be more of an
impartial
arbiter and the dollar be more important
and take more market share
but if you break down into a series of
disconnected regional trading networks
not all of them have a country at its
core that i would consider an economic
power
so when you're looking at certain parts
of the world they're going to lack
access to and influence over any sort of
federal reserve action having another
method of exchange that is not the
physical us dollar
has a role
you'll have to keep the electricity on
you'll have to keep the web working
and some of these places probably aren't
going to be able to manage that but
there are other ways to establish a
method of exchange in an environment
where the us just doesn't care about
half the planet so here's uh a theory
that i have uh i have increasing uh
confidence that this is going to play
out um but i actually think that the us
dollar list uses an example and bitcoin
will rise in strength together
and one way to view it is there's a a uh
a stable coin that is pegged to the
dollars an algorithmic stablecoin today
uh that recently they made the decision
rather than try to use exotic financial
mechanisms where people are arbitraging
risk to keep it at one dollar they
simply are going to get rid of that
system and move to a bitcoin backed
stable coin so it's still a dollar
pegged asset
that is tradable and to your point has
stable value so you remove the
volatility concerns but the value
essentially replicates the gold standard
right it's paper claims on the gold now
you have a digital token valued at one
dollar that's pegged there and it has
some sort of underlying
asset to it
i actually think that some of the weaker
currencies
that is the path in which they
essentially either adopt something to
drive value to their weak currency or
they will fall at the feet of the dollar
right there's consolidation around the
dollar strength and so we see these weak
currencies fail in the face of that
and so
one i guess just like what is your
reaction to that and two have you seen
anything that the weaker currencies are
doing to try to basically survive in the
face of a strengthening dollar and kind
of this world order that seems to be
shifting underneath it
there's um
there were
three strategies one of the strategies
used to be to find a regional poll like
the euro or the yuan to work with uh
that has becoming less and less popular
as people realize just how much the
chinese manipulate the currency and
especially in the in the aftermath of
this round of sanctions against the
russians even the euro is not seen as a
good role for that uh so we're left with
two others uh one is amalgamation where
you have a number of countries that pool
their uh their financial have to make a
regional currency like the caribbean
dollar or uh west africa had the west
over in frank i can't even honestly
remember the status of that right now
it's changed so much in the last two
years
uh or option number three you just peg
it to the dollar you know and that's not
just belize that's de facto hong kong
and taiwan uh you you find ways to link
yourselves into the bond market so even
if the currencies do swing you have
enough exposure so you get brought along
for the swing and that's more or less
what the australians and the kiwis have
been doing for decades
i see a lot more of that moving forward
because the parts of the world that the
us is going to remain engaged in are the
western hemisphere plus southeast asia
and maybe maybe maybe western europe
but if you're talking from about the
brits and the japanese and the us and
canada that's already four members of
the g7 and if you include the rest of
that kind of inner circle zone you're
still talking about two billion people
so either you can be associated with
that countries that have broadly
positive demographic growth and
consumption like growth moving forward
or you can tie yourself onto something
else where security is going to be a
bigger concern for you than the finance
and when that is how people are thinking
that security is more important than
finance i really have a hard time seeing
something like bitcoin coming in out of
the shadows